WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ECONOMY MY NAME IS
SABRINA CERVANTES AYE SERVICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ARE WE
HAVE MANY MEMBERS TODAY JOINING
US HERE AT THE DICE INCLUDING
OUR VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM. WE
ALSO HAVE OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT
TONY SIMONS AND OUR- CONSULTED
WITH THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS SAID
YOU KNOW GO ON. LET ME GO AHEAD
AND JUST START BY MENTIONING
THAT OUR COMMITTEE OFFICE-
SECRETARY DIRTY DEVISE WILL BE.
AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT NUMBER IS NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE. NINE TWENTY
NINETY WHERE SHE CAN BE REACHED
TODAY'S AGENDA INCLUDES TWO
BILLS ITEM ONE. ACR ONE OF FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
RELATING TO A SISTER STATE
AGREEMENT WITH PUNJAB PAKISTAN.
THE SECOND ITEM ACR ONE OH FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HOLDEN
NAZARIAN AND RELATING TO SISTER
STATE AGREEMENT WITH SIR NICK
ARMENIA. THERE ARE NO BILLS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY.
BEFORE WE BEGAN OUR BILL
PRESENTATION I DO NEED TO
PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW HOW
THE PUBLIC WILL BE ABLE TO
PRISON I PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
MUST BE WORN BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WE HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN ROOM. FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THIS FROM LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE JUST
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND YOU CAN
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THAT
TIME. FOR THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. IF ANYONE IS USING
THIS OPTION. IN ADDITION TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM PEOPLE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT MAY USE A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. FOUR DOT
ONE WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE
USING IN A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER IN HERE ROOMS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. AND YOU
WILL BE ASKED BY THE MODERATOR
TO IDENTIFY WHETHER YOU'LL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM%
BROADCASTS AND YOUR SMARTPHONE
DEVICES TO REDUCE ANY SOUND
DISTORTION. THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR COOPERATION AS WE
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT ALL THESE
METHODS TO CONTINUE SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. SO SEEING
THAT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM IF I
CAN ASK OUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THANK YOU CERVANTES. HERE
CERVANTES HERE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HERE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HERE SHALL.
SHALL HEAR HENRY NORRIS. NORRIS
HERE RAMOS SMITH SMITH HERE
MADAM CHAIR YOU HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AND WE ARE
NOW READY TO BEGIN OUR REGULAR
ORDER BUSINESS- LET US BEGIN
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR ONE OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
RELATING TO OUR SISTER STATE
RESOLUTION RELATIONSHIP WITH
PUNJAB PAKISTAN I JOINING MR
HOLDEN IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA BEFORE THE AUTHOR DOES
BEGAN THEIR BILL PRESENTATION
LET ME GIVE EVERYONE NOTICED
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE NOT
OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE. MR HOLDEN ARE YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY MY
APPRECIATIONS TO YOU IN A
COMMITTEE FOR. GIVING US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A C. R.
ONE OH FOUR. IF THEY ARE ONE OF
FOUR WILL CREATE A SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PUNJAB
PAKISTAN AND CALIFORNIA. THIS
IDEA WAS DISCUSSED WELL SPEAKER
RENDON AND MYSELF HOSTED THE
PAKISTAN DELEGATION ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR EARLIER THIS
YEAR. THIS IS THE STATE WILL
ENCOURAGE A MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
RELATIONSHIP. A SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE PROVINCE
OF PUNJAB WOULD PROMOTE MUTUAL
TRADE AND COMMERCE AND INCREASE
THE POTENTIAL FOR EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CULTURAL
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE PROVINCE
OF PUNJAB AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND- JABI
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THE CONSUL
GENERAL PAKISTAN IN LOS
ANGELES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT. THANK YOU THE MANAGER
AND I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR ISRAEL FOR AN
APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- ESTATE
ACR ONE OF FOUR- CRITICISES
STATE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PUNJAB PAKISTAN. AND
CALIFORNIA. AS SOMEONE WHO
SERVED PREVIOUSLY ON THE
NATIONAL BOARD OF SISTER CITIES
INTERNATIONAL- I BELIEVE
STRONGLY IN ITS MISSION IN
PARTICULAR TO. OUR DEVELOP
CITIZEN DIPLOMACY WHICH
ULTIMATELY CREATE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN CITIES
STATES AND ULTIMATELY NATIONS.
AND THERE'S SEVERAL REASONS WHY
PUNJAB IS AN IDEAL SISTERS FOR
CALIFORNIA- ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
AGO PUNJAB INDIA BECAME A
SISTER STAYED WITH. A
CALIFORNIA UP PARTLY BECAUSE OF
THE GIG OF THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY WHICH SIMILARLY IN
PUNJAB POCKETS ON. A DOES MAKE
IT THE BREAD BASKET OF PAKISTAN
AND THE REGION- IN ADDITION
JOBS CAPITAL LAHORE. IS A
CULTURAL HISTORICAL ECONOMIC
AND COST PAULTON CENTER THAT
SERVES AS A NEXUS. FOR THE
CINEMA AND FASHION INDUSTRY IS
ALSO MY FATHER'S BIRTHPLACE-
AND MY FATHER GREW UP IN A
DIFFERENT COLOR WHICH IS ALSO
IN THE STATE. OF PUNJAB. IN
PAKISTAN AND SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO BUILD STRONG RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR STATES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK. YOUR AYE VOTE
AND IS YOUR ONE OF FOR. SO MR
MODERATOR THAT WE HAVE WHICH
MCGOVERN. US STAFF ON THE PHONE
WITH US IN THEY LIKE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ACR ONE OF. FOUR
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
DUMAS AND I AM THAT YOU COULD
BACK TO THE TANK GOVERNOR OF
ANY KIND OF LOCK IT. SHOULD
BERKELEY COULD NOT MAKE IT
TODAY BUT YEAH IF YOU GOT HER
BEHALF AND SHARE HER SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY ARE ONE OF FOUR.
FIFTY- THINK RELATIONSHIPS LIKE
THE ONE PROPOSED HERE PROVIDE A
VITAL MECHANISM TO STRENGTHEN.
TIES BETWEEN THE THREE STATES.
M. COOPERATION ON ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA.
IMMIGRANT FROM PAKISTAN HAVE
COME TO CALIFORNIA TO PURSUE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. TO
START THE BENEFITS AND TO RAISE
THEIR FAMILY. IN THE PROCESS
THEY HAVE BUILT IN DURING
CULTURAL AND COMMERCIAL
RELATIONSHIP. I CONTINUE TO
UNITE OUR PEOPLE. PAKISTANI
CALIFORNIANS ACTIVE IN ALL
WALKS OF LIFE. IN OUR GOLDEN
STATE. AND ARE KEY NEED. IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE WONDERFUL.
DIVERSE SOCIETY. I MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE VESSEL. THROUGH
THE FIFTY STATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PROVINCE OF PUNJAB WE
CAN STRENGTHEN THOSE PERSON TO
PERSON TIES. AND WORK TOWARDS A
BETTER FUTURE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. LET ME NOW ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING.
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I SEE AN
ANSWER. ARE THERE ANYWAY. IN
THE REMOTE TEST STATION.
HEARING THAT MR MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AT
THE TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
LET US HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. C.
NINE SERGEANTS IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE TESTIMONY. STATION.
HEARING NONE MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
CONFERENCE LINE WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. NOW IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE TO
ANY MEMBERS WISH TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL. BY
SOMEONE NUMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
IS THERE A SECOND. SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN DO YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS-
JUST TO SAY THAT THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EXCITEMENT
ENTHUSIASM WITHIN THE PROJECT
THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE EXPECT THAT
THIS WILL BE NOT JUST AN
INVITATION BUT IT WILL BE
REALIZED IN BOTH. OUR COUNTRIES
TO BE ABLE TO SEE IT COME TO
FRUITION AND THAT THEY'LL BE
REAL- ENGAGEMENT ARE GOING
FORWARD SO WITHOUT KNOWING THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST ASKING FOR
PERMISSION TO HAVE THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH ANOTHER
PROFIT WITH THE PROVINCE OF BUT
KNOWING THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
EXCITEMENT ON BOTH ENDS TO MAKE
SURE IT WORKS SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MEMBERS
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION ON ACR ONE OF
FOUR IS TO BE A DOCTOR WITH THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SURE CERVANTES HI
SHARE CERVANTES I'D BUY EXTRA
CUNNINGHAM. LAST YEAR
CUNNINGHAM HIGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. SUMMER
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TRAVEL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHECK OUT HI SUMMER PETRIE
NORRIS. ASSEMBLY CHECK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATRICK NORRIS HI SUMMER
MEMORABLES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT.
SUMMER SMITH HI. MEMBERS OF ON
A SEVEN TWO ZERO ACR ONE OF
FOUR IS OUT. HERE ACR ONE OF
FIVE PRICE. HOLDEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KNOWS ARIANNA RELATING
TO SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOUR NECK ARMENIA ARE WE
ALSO HAVE SENATOR PORTANTINO
WHO WILL BE JOINING US FOR THIS
PRESENTATION. BEFORE THE AUTHOR
BEGAN THEIR BILL PRESENTATION
LET ME GIVE EVERYONE NOTICED
THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW
OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE THAT CALL NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND- THAT WALK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDING
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
IDENTIFIED INCOME AT ELEVEN OF
THE BILL ANALYSIS. AND MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL ADOPT
THESE AMENDMENTS MR HOLDEN U.
B. YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A C. R.
ONE OH FIVE TODAY. FIRST EXCEPT
AS OF JUST ON THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE REFERENCE
TO THE MAY TWELFTH A CONFLICT.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE OH FIVE WILL ESTABLISH
SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA IN THE
PROVINCE OF SONIC AND ARMENIA.
SINICA'S THE SOUTHERNMOST
PROVINCE IN ARMENIAN HAS
PROFOUND HISTORICAL AND
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE FOR
ARMENIA AND THE WORLD. IT IS
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL PROVINCES
OF THE ANCIENT KINGDOM OF
ARMENIA IS ALSO HOME TO ARMENIA
STONE ARMENIAN STONEHENGE WHICH
DATES BACK TO THE BRONZE AGE
AND HAS. PETROGLYPH FIX THAT
ARE SEVEN THOUSAND YEARS OLD
SINICA'S IS RUBBER ARMENIANS AS
THE BACKBONE OF OUR MEDIA AS IT
IS ESSENTIAL TO IMPORTING AND
EXPORTING GOODS FROM THE SELF.
WHY IS TRADE FROM THE SELF SO
CRITICAL SINICA'S BORDERED BY
ARSHAQ. ARTSAKH AZERBAIJAN AND
IRAN. SINCE AZERBAIJAN AND
TURKEY WERE ENGAGED IN AN
ECONOMIC BLOCKADE BLOCKAGE OF
ARMENIA WITHOUT ABOUT JOHN
BORDER IN THE EAST AND WEST
SENECA IS A TRADE LIFELINE TO
ARMENIA FOR ITS BORDER WITH
IRAN. STRIP IN OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH SOON IT COMES AT A
CRITICAL TIME AS REGIONAL
POWERS LIKE AZERBAIJAN AND
TURKEY POSE A THREAT TO ITS
EXISTENCE. IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY FAILED TO SPEAK OR
ACT AS OBSERVERS ON RENEWED
WAR. AGAINST THE ARMENIANS OF
NAGORNO KARABAKH REPUBLIC WHICH
BORDERS TUNIC. IN ABSENCE OF
INTERNATIONAL PRESSURE. THE
AZERBAIJANI MILITARY CROSSED
INTO THE REPUBLIC OF ARMENIA
AND MOVED THREE POINT FIVE
KILOMETERS INTO SENATE PROVINCE
SEIZING THE ENTIRE. ENTIRETY OF
SIEVE LAKE. I'VE BEEN A GREAT
SUPPORTER OF ARMENIA AND THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY OVER THE
YEARS THIS YEAR I INTRODUCED AB
TEN NINETEEN WHICH RESTRICTS
INVESTMENT IN TURKEY FOR THEIR
CONTINUED DENIAL OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND THE
SUPPORT OF CURRENT AGGRESSIONS
TOWARDS ARMENIA. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALPERS GREATLY REDUCED THEIR
EXPOSURE TO TURKISH INVESTMENT.
THIS RESOLUTION REAFFIRMS
CALIFORNIA SOLIDARITY WITH
ARMENIA. AN HOUR ONE MILLION
STRONG COMMUNITY OF OUR
CALIFORNIA ARMENIANS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. MISTER IS THERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE THE
SENATOR IS ON A SHORT TIME LINE
SO I WOULD YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY
CHAU THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
AND THANK YOU- CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN FOR BRING THIS. FORWARD
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
OBVIOUSLY. IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THE CITY OF GLENDALE
BECAME THE EPICENTER OF THE
ARMENIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. I GLENDALE
CONTINUES TO BE THE CENTER OF-
I MEAN THE VIBRANT ARMENIAN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY AND I'M
PROUD TO REPRESENT- GLENDALE-
THERE ARE MULTIPLE SHOPS
GROCERY STORES BAKERIES DELIS.
OF POLITICIANS COMMUNITY
LEADERS SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS-
IT IS A VIBRANT A VIBRANT
COMMUNITY THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA. AND VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND OBVIOUSLY
TO THE TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
OVER HERE- PROMOTING THIS
RESOLUTION- THERE ARE. DUAL
IMMERSION LANGUAGE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE CENTRAL TO IN PRODUCING THE
ARMENIAN LANGUAGE NOT ONLY TO
ARMENIAN STUDENTS BUT TO NOT
ARMENIAN STUDENTS- THE ARMENIAN
CAUCUS- THIS YEAR IN ITS-
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. MANY OF
THE WINNERS WERE NON ARMENIAN
SO THAT THE SPREAD OF ESPRIT DE
CORPS AND THE SPREAD OF THE
COMMUNITY IS IMPORTANT. AND
WITH IN THAT VIBRANCY THERE ARE
MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS AND MANY
RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT WHO
ARE FROM IT'S UNIQUE. AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THIS REAL CONNECTION. FROM
CALIFORNIA TO THIS REGION MANY
OF THEM HAVE FAMILY FRIENDS-
ACR ONE OF FIVE WILL BE
CONNECTING AND BE THE BRIDGE
INVITING PEOPLE FROM THE
PROVINCE OF SYUNIK TO JOIN
CALIFORNIAN THE SISTER STATE.
RELATIONSHIP UNTIL OBVIOUSLY
JANUARY TWENTY ONE JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SIX
IT WILL FURTHER PROMOTE THE
PROSPERITY OF BOTH REGIONS AND
IMPROVE INTERNATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING. OF AND GOOD WILL
IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE AND
FACILITATE MUTUAL BENEFICIAL
EDUCATION ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
EXCHANGE- TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
WAS A HARD YEAR FOR ARMENIA AND
ARTSAKH. NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO BECAUSE
OF THE ARTSAKH WAR. ON THE
MONTHS THAT FOLLOWED THE FORTY
FOUR DAY WAR WE'RE NOT PEACEFUL
EITHER- THERE CONTINUE TO BE
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES BEING
RAISED THERE CONTINUES TO BE
PRISONERS OF WAR. THAT ARE
BEING HELD- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO STAND WITH THE
COMMUNITY THE PROVINCE OF
SYUNIK BEING LOCATED IN THE
SOUTHERNMOST SIDE OF ARMENIA
WAS THE TARGET OF AN
ADVANCEMENT OF THE ARTS VERY
MILITARY FORCES. I SAW FIRST
HAND WHEN I WAS IN AUG DOWN.
THE IS VERY TANKS THAT WERE A
HUNDRED YARDS AWAY FROM THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
ARTSAKH ARMY WHO WERE DEFENDING
THEIR HOMELAND. THIS WAS A
TRAGEDY THAT WE SHOULD ALL
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE- THE AS
ARIE'S SEASON ENTIRE SERVE LAKE
THE NEXT DAY THE AZERBAIJANI
MILITARY BREACH TO OTHER
SECTIONS OF THE BORDER. MOVING
TOWARD THE RESIDENTIAL AREAS
OCCUPIED MORE AREAS OF THE
SOVEREIGN TERRITORY. OF THE
REPUBLIC ARMENIA. ALTHOUGH WITH
RUSSIAN MEDIA'S MEDIATION ARE
YOUR FOR JOHN AGREED TO
WITHDRAW TO THEIR PRE MAY
TWELFTH POSITIONS ARMENIA
REPORTS SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE
STILL AZERBAIJANI SOLDIERS
REMAINING ILLEGALLY. IN SCENIC
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I
INTRODUCED SB THREE OH TWO TO
REESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
ARMENIAN TRADE OFFICE. IN HOPES
OF BUILDING A VIBRANT BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND THIS YEAR- I HELPED
NEGOTIATE WITH PERSON STIRS
THEIR HISTORIC ACTION. TO
CHANGE THEIR INVESTMENT POLICY
IN TURKEY BECAUSE TURKEY HAS
BEEN SUPPORTING THESE EFFORTS.
RATHER THAN RE ESTABLISH OUR
TRADE OFFICE- THE GOVERNOR
CHOSE TO NEGOTIATE M. O. U.
WITH ARMENIA TO ESTABLISH A
TRADE DESK IN YEREVAN BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA. AND IMPACT OF AND
THAT WAS SIGNED EARLIER THIS
YEAR SO CALIFORNIA'S DOING MANY
MANY IMPORTANT THINGS TO
RESPECT THE VIBRANT ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY. AND THIS RESOLUTION
WILL CONTINUE TO VERIFY OUR
COMMITMENT NOT JUST TO ARMENIA
AND ARMENIANS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE SPIRIT OF ARMENIANS
AROUND THE WORLD AND CERTAINLY
OUR HEART GOES OUT TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR TALK AND I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
BEEN THERE AS WELL. AND JOIN ME
IN JUST SAYING HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS TO CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS MEASURE FORWARD
INTO INVITING MYSELF AS WELL AS
THE SENATOR TO JOIN HIM IN IN
THIS EFFORT I VERY MUCH VALUE
YOUR WORK VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE. AND
WANTED TO SPEAK UP ON IT SO
THANK YOU- THANK YOU TO THE
SENATOR FOR PORTRAYING A GREAT
CHRONOLOGY OF- BOTH LONG TERM
AS WELL AS VERY IMMEDIATE SHORT
TERM EVENTS THAT HAVE A-
DEVASTATED THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY AND UP ALL OVER THE
WORLD BUT- GIVEN WHAT A HOT IT
IS IN CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY IN
LOS ANGELES AREA HOW IT'S
IMPACTED MANY INDIVIDUALS NOT
BECAUSE A FAMILY MEMBER OR
RELATIVE STILL LIVING THERE BUT
BECAUSE OF HOW IT'S BEING
VIEWED AS A RECURRING THEME. OF
THE NEIGHBORS THAT SURROUND
ARMENIA- JUST THE HISTORICAL
CONTEXT A BRIEF HUNDRED AND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIX YEARS
AGO- THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
ERADICATE. AN INDIGENOUS
POPULATION LIVING IN AN AREA
THAT HAD BEEN THERE FOR FIVE
THOUSAND YEARS. AND- WHILE THE
LAST HUNDRED YEARS HAVE SEEN
MANY SHIFTING POLITICAL TIDES
SOVIET UNION WAS ESTABLISHED
SANMINA FELL UNDER THE
UMBRELLA- OF THE SOVIET UNION-
AND THEN GAINED INDEPENDENCE
SINCE BEEN INDEPENDENT FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND IT'S BEEN
STRIVING TO BECOME A PARTNER OF
THE UNITED STATES IT'S BEEN
TAKING STEPS TO ADDRESS
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES HEALTH CARE
ISSUES TRANSPORTATION AND
LOGISTICS GIVEN THAT IT'S A
LANDLOCKED COUNTRY. AND IT
HASN'T KNOWN EXACTLY HOW TO
SOMETIMES UNFORTUNATELY WORK
WITH ITS NEIGHBORS BECAUSE OF
ITS NEIGHBORS DON'T REALLY WANT
TO WORK WITH. THEY STILL HAVE
THE IDEA AND CONCEPT OF
ERADICATING IT AND HE TOOK
THOSE STEPS JUST LAST FALL. IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE WORLD
PANDEMIC WHICH WE'VE NOT
EXPERIENCED. IN THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS. SEVERITY OF
WHICH WE HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED-
AND DURING THE TIME OF A BUT
MINUTES US ADMINISTRATION THAT
DID NOT NECESSARILY CARE ABOUT.
WHAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN TO THIS
TINY POPULATION THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH AND IS A
STE POTENTIALLY A VERY STRONG
ALLY OF OUR COUNTRY SO. AS MANY
OF YOU HAVE HEARD AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
SUPPORT HERE DURING THE
GENOCIDE COMMEMORATION MONTH OF
APRIL AND SUPPORTING THE
ARMENIAN. GENOCIDE RESOLUTIONS
UNANIMOUSLY BUT I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALSO EVERYONE. I
BELIEVE ALMOST EVERY WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF MAYBE ONE MEMBER
WHO WASN'T ELECTED AT THE TIME
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN VOTING
TO SUPPORT THE DIVESTMENT BILL.
WHICH GOVERNOR NEWSOM ALSO
SIGNED WHICH TELLS YOU WHAT THE
MORAL COMPASS OF OUR STATE IS
WE'RE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THEY STILL HELD TO
OUTDATED GEOPOLITICAL AND OIL
INTERESTS. AND SO IT FOCUSES ON
NARROWLY CONSTRUCTED PARADIGMS.
OF PAST GENERATIONS. AND SO
UNTIL OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
COMES TO A PLACE WHERE IT
REALIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING ALLIANCES WITH COUNTRIES
THAT BELIEVE IN THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC. FREEDOMS AND IDEAS
ESPOUSE THE SAME IDEAS THAT
ALSO WANT TO SEE A WORLD WHERE
WE ADDRESS CLIMATE ISSUES WE
ADDRESS TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENTS
WE ADDRESS HEALTH CARE CONCERNS
AND ISSUES- IT'S CRITICAL FOR
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA TO
SOMETIMES STEP UP AND FILL THAT
VOID. OUT SO AS AS SOMEONE WHO-
HAS A GREAT HONOR OF BEING IN
OFFICE AND REPRESENT MY
DISTRICT- BUT ALSO BEING- THE
THIRD GENERATION ARMENIAN WHO
IN THE LAST HUNDRED AND TEN
YEARSOF THOSE THREE
GENERATIONS MY FAMILY HAS HAD
TO MOVE FOUR TIMES WHETHER
BECAUSE OF THE GENOCIDE THE
STALINIST PURGES THE RUSSIAN
REVOLUTION OR THE IRANIAN
REVOLUTION AND WAR WITH IRAQ
WHICH LED ME AT EIGHT YEARS OF
AGE TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES- I DON'T SEE IT AS AN
ARMENIAN AMERICAN BUT- AS- A-
CALIFORNIAN. WHO WANTS TO
SUPPORT OTHER COUNTRIES. WHO
UNFORTUNATELY ARE BEING BULLIED
AND THE MEDIA COVERAGE IS
FAILING TO REALLY ADDRESS
WHAT'S AT THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE. SO WE NEED TO BE
RECOGNIZING THAT TAKING STEPS
TO SUPPORT AND THE MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN WE SAY NEVER AGAIN.
AT IT ACTUALLY MEANS SOMETHING
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE AND AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER FOR ENTERTAINING THIS
MIGHT MEASURE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY MISTER
MODERATOR I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE AMBASSADOR ARMEN BY
PORTION ON THE LINE VIDEO LINE
WITH US WHO LIKE TO DRESS THE
COMMITTEE ON ACR ONE OH FIVE.
WE MAY BE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY CONNECTING LET ME GO
AHEAD AND. ON THE FRONT DOOR
YES. WELL LET ME GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEN NONE- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT I CAN HEAR YOU ANTI
CAN'T SPEAK IF YOU WOULD LIKE
THIS IS A MATTER ARM AND BY
PLEDGE. AMBASSADOR WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM READY.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. HONORABLE
PRESIDENT SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO FROM
DAHLE SAID TO COMMAND THE
RESOLUTION FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OLD SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND SHOEMAKER. SHE ONLY IS ONE
OF THE PROVINCES IN ARMENIA AND
MAY BE ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE BEING THE FATHER
MOST PART OF ARMENIA AND THE
BILL NUMBER IS STIPULATED BY
THE FACT. THAT AZERBAIJAN NOT
ONLY TO MEET CROSS BORDER
INCURSIONS INTO THE SOVEREIGN
TERRITORY OF ARMENIA BUT ALSO
OPENLY PRESENTS TERRITORIAL
CLAIMS TOWARDS THAT REGION AND
OTHER PARTS OF ARMENIA. IN THIS
CONTEXT I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION
THAT. THE STATE'S SOVEREIGN
TERRITORY OF ARMENIA AND THESE.
THIRD CITY RELATIONSHIP
RESOLUTION SAYING THAT
NATURALLY DEVELOPING. ECONOMIC
EDUCATIONAL CULTURAL RELATIONS
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND TUNIC
BUT THAT THE SAME TIME I SHOULD
SAY THAT THE RESOLUTION AND-
RELATIONSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP ON
THIS LEVEL WILL CERTAINLY
CONTRIBUTE. AND TO THE AMATE
MAINTAIN INSULT PEACE IN THE
REGION AND WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
THE- THAT'S MENTAL RELATIONSHIP
AND STABILITY IN THE REGION I
DIDN'T K. SO VERY MANY OTHER
SITUATIONS SIMILAR TO THE
INTERNATIONALLY THESE KIND OF-
AGREEMENTS. AIMED AT. JUST
DEVELOPING CULTURALLY. ECONOMIC
RELATIONS PLAYED VERY IMPORTANT
STOP ALLIES IN CORAL IN THIS
CONTEXT I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT THE EUROPEAN UNION FIFTEEN
JULY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
PROVIDED OR PLEDGE TO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE IN THE
INVESTMENTS TO ARMENIA INTO
MOUNT DORA THREE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS AND THE
MAJORITY OF THE AMOUNT WILL BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS HIM WEEK IT'S
NOT ONLY ABOUT. EIGHT
UNDERINVESTMENT IN THE COUNTRY
AND CREATION OF JOBS IN TO
SOLVE THEIR MOST MOST REGION OF
SUNY BUT IT'S ALSO ALONG WITH
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IT'S ABOUT
STABILITY APPALLED PEACE IN THE
REGION AND. I WANT TO REITERATE
THAT. BUT OPTIONAL THIS RESULT
I'M TO STOP THIS RENTALS CITY
WILL BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE PROVINCE OF
SYUNIK IN ARMENIA. GOING TO
HE'S GOING TO PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN. THAT MATCH
ADVANCEMENT THE PEACE SITUATION
IN THE REGION. I ALSO WANTS TO
REITERATE AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY MUCH EAGER
TO SEE THE RELATIONSHIP
ADVANCED THINKING THIS
DIRECTION ESPECIALLY AUTHORED
THE PROGRESSION ARE THERE BUT
JONS AGAINST NOT GONNA
CARLEBACH AGAINST ARTSAKH
UNKNOWN YOU INCURSIONS AGAINST
THE SOVEREIGNTY TERRITORIAL
FARMING SOUL ARMENIA WANTS
PEACE ARMENIAN PEOPLE WANTS
PEACE. AND PEACE RESOLUTION.
I'M STILL SOME PEACE AND THOSE
WHO DON'T WANT PEACE NATURALLY
WILL BE TRYING TO. BACK AGAIN
THIS RESOLUTION UNDER GAINES.
PUBLISHED MENTAL SIX THIRD
STREET A RELATIONSHIP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TO YOUR
ATTENTION AND I AM READY TO
PROVIDE ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY PEOPLE WILL BE BUILT
WELL THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN BASTAR LET ME NOW
ASK- IF THERE IS ANYONE IN THE
ROMO TESTAMENTI STATION WHO
LIKE TO PROVIDE. SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL. HEARING NONE I SEE
NO ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE I WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. SHE AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. WE
DO HAVE A FEW IN OUR QUEUE-
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE TWENTY
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO
IS VIRGINITY FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO COMMENT ON THIS RESOLUTION-
BECAUSE WE DID TRY TO GET INTO
THE HEARING TODAY IN PERSON BUT
WE WERE THREATENED WITH THE
WRATH. AND FOLKS ARE TRYING TO
CALL IN TO GET COMMENT IS THE
TIME TO DO THAT. WE'RE TAKING
SUPPORT. ON ACR ONE OH FIVE AT
THE MOMENT. I WAS. BUILT ABOUT
ARMENIAN- RELATIONSHIP TO MY IN
THE RIGHT COMMITTEE I WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE BUILDING WITH
SOME OTHER PEOPLE WHO YOU
THREATEN WITH THE RATS WE WERE
JUST TRYING TO GET INTO THIS
HEARING TODAY I JUST DON'T WANT
TO BE IN THE WRONG PLACE DO I
GET. INSTANCES BEACON TYPICALLY
WHAT THE CHAIR DíAS THIS IS IN
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF A SER
ONE OF FIVE SISTER. STATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH SCENIC
ARMENIA. YOU MAY BE GONE. CLICK
SO DO I GET TO MINUTES. YOU MAY
YOU MAY PERCEIVE THAT WHEN I
GET A PROCEED YOU HAVE A MINUTE
TO PROCEED IN SUPPORT. OKAY I'M
IN SUPPORT I'M DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT OF KEEPING-
RELATIONSHIPS GOOD WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES I THINK THAT KIND OF
STANDS TO REASON THAT ANYBODY
WOULD YOU KNOW HALF A BRAIN
WOULD BE IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
BUT IT SEEMS ODD TO ME RIGHT
NOW THAT YOU PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON. CALIFORNIA
IS BURNING UP FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO FLY FOR
PUBLIC PROFILE. YOU CAN'T EVEN
MANAGE THE POWER YOU CAN'T
MANAGE THE DMV. YOU CAN'T
MANAGE THE CPUC YOU CAN'T
MANAGE THE EDT. CHILDREN ARE
KILLING THEMSELVES DUE TO THE
STATE PANDEMIC. I'M HERE HAVING
A SPECIAL HEARING FOR
RELATIONSHIPS. WITH COUNTRIES.
ACROSS THE WORLD OF COURSE WE
WANT PEACE. BUT THE LIGHTS
DON'T WORK. SO I THINK ACTUALLY
UPON SECOND THOUGHT I THINK YOU
BETTER REACH YOU ME. BECAUSE
I'VE DECIDED. UNFORTUNATELY I'M
OPPOSED TO THAT. SO CAN YOU PUT
ME BACK HUNDRED CAN YOU PLEASE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT. WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. ABSOLUTELY AND NEXT
WILL BE GOING TO NUMBER
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- THIS IS EDWARD
BOSTON YOUNG WITH THE ARMENIAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF AMERICA
WESTERN REGION AND I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR HDR ONE OH FIVE. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS NEAR ON TOO MUCH ON
THE ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF
AMERICA AND MY ORGANIZATION IS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PASSAGE OF ACR ONE OH FIVE. ARE
THERE AT THE TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE WHAT DOES NOT HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE- THE
CONSUL GENERAL OF THE REPUBLIC
OF AZERBAIJAN TO WESTERN
STATES. ON THE LINE. HELLO AND
IT HIT ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOUR
THAT DISTINGUISHES OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU DISTINGUISH
COMMITTEE CHAIR DISTINGUISHED
REMEMBERS YEAH LAWMAKERS THAT
LEGISLATOR THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
POSITION REGARDING THE
RESOLUTION HDR HUNDRED FIVE AS
OUTLINED IN MY LETTER FROM OVER
TWENTY IT WE HAVE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SEVERAL PARAGRAPHS
CONTAINING DISTRIBUTION. SAID
BAGHDAD PUT THAT IN CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN EXTREMELY COMPLEX FOREIGN
POLICY ISSUE RELATING TO
RELATIONS BETWEEN ARMENIA
AZERBAIJAN. ALMOST SEVEN
THOUSAND MILES AWAY. THESE
DISTORTED TARGET AN THE HUMAN
OF THE BY AND IT'S- AND WHICH
IS A FOR AN AND LONG TO PARTNER.
OF THE UNITED STATES. HERE ARE
SOME SOLID FACT. THE NUMBER OF
THE CAR ABOUT REGENT SEVEN
ADJACENT DISTRICTS OF
AZERBAIJAN ALMOST 20% OF
AZERBAIJAN'S SOVEREIGN COUNTRY
VERY LEGALLY INVADED AND
OCCUPIED BY ARMENIA DURING THE
WAR IT UNLEASHED AGAINST
AZERBAIJAN IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES. AS A RESULT
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DIVIDENDS
WHAT YOU'LL HUNDRED THOUSAND
WERE WOUNDED AND NEARLY EIGHTY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND AT THE
BEGINNING AND WE'RE. EXPELLED
FROM THEIR HOMES AND LAND. THE
U. N. SECURITY CA IT WILL SHOCK.
AND INVASION AND CLEANSING
DEMANDING. OF THE ARMENIAN
OCCUPYING FORCES FROM OTHER BY
JOHN. AFTER THE INVASION I YOU
NEED TOUGHNESS AND ILLEGALLY
JEAN IN OTHER BY JOB. TERRITORY
CALLING IT CODE NAGORNO
KARABAKH REPUBLIC OR QUOTE THE
PUBLIC ART. THE TRYING TO THE
NATIONAL COMMUNITY BEGIN STATES
GOVERNMENT AND UNITED NATIONS
RECOGNIZED DAY REGIONAL CAR
ABOUT AS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE REPUBLIC OF AZERBAIJAN. NO
COUNTRY NOT EVEN ARMENIA HAS
RECOGNIZED THE TOP OF THE
PUBLIC OF ARTSAKH. IF THE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIVE THAT JET THAT'S
UNIQUE IS BORDERED BY THE
FOOTBALL THE PUBLIC OF OCT. THE
TRUTH EIGHT THE PROBABLY
DISPUTING IT BORDERED BY THE
REPUBLIC OF AZERBAIJAN BOTH ON
THE WEST AND EAST. THE U. S.
AND INTERNATIONAL POSITION. ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ARMENIA
LAUNCHED ANOTHER WAR OF
AGGRESSION AGAINST AZERBAIJAN
ARMENIA BOMB OUR MAJOR CITIES
OUTSIDE THE WAR ZONE USING EVEN
THE WIDELY BANNED CLUSTER
MUNITIONS. ACHIEVEMENT RIGHTS
WATCH AND AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL
HAVE BURNED. AT THE RESULT
HUNDRED ONE AT THE BEGINNING
CIVILIANS INCLUDING TWELVE
SMALL CHILDREN GOT KILLED. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE CIVILIANS
WERE WOUNDED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND AT THE BEGINNING GOOD
DISPLAY. OF THE BUDGET LOOK FOR
THREE SPONSORED DEFENDED THE
BDS AND PREVENT FURTHER
AGGRAVATION BY I MEAN. ALL THE
FIGHTING TOOK PLACE WITHIN THE
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
BORDERS ABOUT THE BUT JOHN
WHICH DEFENDED ITS TERRITORY
INTEGRITY ON ITS OWN SO BUT
POINT FORCES. ON NOVEMBER TENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THE WAR
ENDED WITH A CEASE FIRE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH WHICH ARMENIA
AGREED TO RECOGNIZE THE RESULT
OF THE WAR AND RETREAT FROM
ADDITIONAL WE DID SPEAK ABOUT
THE BY JOHN. THAT'S OTHER BUT
JOHN INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
TERRITORY INTEGRITY WAS
RESTORED AND THE U. N. SECURITY
COMPETITION IMPLEMENTED. IT
WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR NOW OVER
ONE MILLION POSTED THE DISPLAY
AT THE BUDGET IS TO FINALLY
RETURN TO THEIR ANCESTRAL
LANDS. A DIVERSION UNIT SHE HAD
NOT CROSSED INTO THE REPUBLIC
OF ARMENIA AS THE EIGHT HUNDRED
BY TO GET. OFF THE REGULATION
OF ITS TENTH STREET FROM
OCCUPATION AND RESTORATION OF
ITS SOUTHERN BORDER WITH
ARMENIA. YOU KNOW THE VERSION
BORDER. BASED ON SUBJECT MATTER
AVAILABLE TO EACH OF THE SITE
THAT DEFINES OUR INTERSTATE
BORDER WE HAVE REPEATEDLY URGED
I NEED TO START NEGOTIATIONS ON
BORDER DELIMITATION AND-
SPEAKING. ARMENIA HAS
UNFORTUNATELY REFUSED THIS. IS
THE BUDGET IS A STRONG FRIEND
AND PARTNER OF THE UNITED
STATES OUR TWO COUNTRIES ENJOY
VITAL COOPERATION IN THE FIELD
ASK YOU DID YOU GET ENERGY
DIVERSIFICATION
COUNTERTERRORISM AND
NONPROLIFERATION. THE UNITED
STATES HAS ALSO REPEATEDLY
UNDER BOTH DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS.
THEY DID. IT STRONG SUPPORTER.
OF THE BUT JOHN. THE LATEST AT
THE MANY DOLLARS FROM. WHAT THE
FACT THAT I W. THE SECRET
REMAINS A KABUL INTO AIRPORT IN
A FUNNY. ALONGSIDE YOU EXTRA
HELPING THE SIX OF THE AIRPORT
I THINK IF. OF THE U. S. AND
EUROPEAN NASH. WHICH THAT YOU
S. AND HAS OFFICIALLY THANK
THAT THE BUDGET. I BEGIN ARMING
OUR WORKING TO GET THAT WITHIN
A NEW STAFF INTO. WORKING GROUP
ON ON BLOW COLD TO. AND
NORMALIZING IT WOULD BE REALLY.
WITH UNDERSTANDING IF VERY
COMPLEX AND PROJECT POLICY. AT
THE UNITED STATES IS ONE OF THE
MEDIATOR. HAVING A BIG STAKE IN
THE NORMALIZATION OF OTHER
BEGIN ARMENIAN RELATIONS AND
ACHIEVEMENT OF DURABLE PEACE
AND STABILITY IN THE REGION.
BAYPORT EIGHTY HUNDREDS WHICH
CONTRADICTS US FOREIGN POLICY
AND INTERNATIONAL LOW WOULD
SEND THE WRONG MESSAGE AND
TREMENDOUS THE DAMAGE. HONEST
BROKER IMAGE OF THE UNITED
STATES. IN VIEW OF THE
AFOREMENTIONED I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE POSITION I'M
REJECTED EVEN IDEATION ABOUT
THE BUDGET ON ITS PEOPLE AND AT
THE BUDGET AMERICAN COMMUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY BEFORE WE CONTINUE
WILL HELP WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS
ARE I DO WANNA MENTION PUBLIC
COMMENT MUST RELATE TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILLS BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY I SEE NO ONE.
DURING HER. SEE NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION A SERGEANTS IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. HEARING
NONE MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CONFERENCE
CONFERENCE I WHO LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PROPOSITION. WE
DO HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GET. MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM AND MY AFFILIATION IS. A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE ON MY MIGUEL TIMER AND I'M
A MOTHER OF FOUR SHARES FOR
MINOR WE TIMELINE. IT IS
ACTUALLY. RELATED I'M GIVING
YOU MY AFFILIATION. I WAS
TELLING YOU WHO I AM AS THE
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW THAT MY TURN
TO SPEAK MY OPPOSITION. I'D
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IS
ABOUT WHAT THIS HEARING IS
ABOUT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
THE PEOPLE AND WHAT THE PEOPLE
THINK THIS TESTIMONY IS IN
OPPOSITION TO ACR ONE OH FIVE
SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
SO NICK ARMENIA. I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS RESOLUTION USE THAT HAVE
TO RELATE. TO THE CONTENT AND
THE TOPIC AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO. YOU MAIL IN MY
MIND TO BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK.
YOU MAY PROCEED. I'M NOT REALLY
FORTY I'M NOT PART OF THE WORLD
WHAT I CAN SAY IS FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LOST EVERYTHING IN THE
FIRE IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT MAYBE YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE A LITTLE BIT
SKEWED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME YOU HAVE YOUR HANDS
FULL OF THE PROBLEMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THE FIRE. TO
THE FACT THAT YOU CAN'T KEEP
THE POWER ON YES WE WANT PEACE
THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIANS WANT
THE CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE
PEACE HOME BURNING. IN VERY BAD.
THEY CAN'T GET THEIR- TRACK
BURKE CHILDREN UNDERGOING THAT
HE FELL MOVE FOR YOU TO REPAIR.
THIS. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. MR HOLDEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE.
BEFORE I MOVED TO THE AUTHOR OF
THEIR ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
CENA NINE MR HOLDER MISTER
NAZARIAN- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED I STILL DO NOT HAVE A
MOTION OUR SECOND. WILL MOTION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I YOU
KNOW I THIS IS A RESOLUTION TO
OF IDENTIFY AND HIGHLIGHT. OF
THE COMMONALITIES BETWEEN A
PROVINCE IN ARMENIA AND
CALIFORNIA. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE
ARTSAKH THROUGH A J. R. THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIKE OTTO
AT THE TIME AND SO THIS BILL IN
THIS RESOLUTION IS CONSISTENT
WITH ALREADY STATED. I'LL SEE
IF HE WILL OF CALIFORNIA. OF
THE STATE IS ALSO TAKEN A
POSITION TO A RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE- BY TURKEY AGAINST THE
PEOPLE OF ARMENIA. THE
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES
JUST RECENTLY DID AS MUCH. BUT
OUR FOCUS IS REALLY TO SEE HOW
WE CAN BUILD A RELATIONSHIP.
WITH ANOTHER PART OF THE WORLD
THAT SO MANY IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
FAMILY AND IDENTIFY WITH. AND
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE WE CAN BUILD ON. WHAT OUR
COMMONALITIES ARE. WORSE RENTS
ARE AND WHERE WE CAN LEARN FROM
ONE ANOTHER. IT'S WITHIN THAT
SPIRIT THAT ACR ONE OH FIVE IS
BEING PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY.
THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE DONE
TO WORK WITH BOTH. SONIC AND
ALSO CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE'S A
LARGE DELEGATION OF SUPPORT
THAT WILL BREATHE LIFE INTO
THIS RELATIONSHIP. IN BOTH
PARTS OF THE WORLD AND I THINK
THAT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU WE
NEED MORE OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
THEN IN BRING IN GOOD WILL AND
HOPEFULLY COMMONALITY TOGETHER-
AS OPPOSED TO SORT OF THE
DIVISIVENESS THAT SEEMS TO BE
EXIST SO I WORKED WITH THAT THE
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I WOULD TURN TO- MY JOINT
AUTHORS IF HE HAD A CLOSING
THOUGHT AS WELL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD WHAT I'VE ALREADY SAID
AND I THINK AGAIN THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA FOR.
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS I WOULD GIVEN THAT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND THE
MOTION ON ACR ONE OF FIVE IS TO
BE ADOPTED WITH AMENDMENTS IF
OUR CHIEF CONSULTING- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SURE CERVANTES I
CARE CERVANTES I VICE YOU'RE
CUNNINGHAM. FASTER CUNNINGHAM
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. NUMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY MEMBER%
CAL STAR MEMBER CATTLE I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PICTURE NORRIS.
SO I PETRIE NORRIS I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS SO REMEMBER RAMOS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH HI. ON A BIRD
SEVEN TWO ZERO ACR ONE OF FIVE
IS OUT SO I MEMBERS THIS DOES
CONCLUDE TODAY'S ORDER BUSINESS
WE ARE DROWNED.